à l'issue des deux tours de mars et juin
2020 la part des femmes mères est à la
hausse dans le 78 92 entre 2014 et 2020
leur proportion augmente de 5 points
dépassant les 22 % les hauts-de-seine
voit même 25 % des communes dirigées par
des femmes
en france la progression est de 3 points
entre 2014 et 2020
là où il ya eu un progrès dans les
yvelines c'est que elles ont été
beaucoup plus nombreuses et tête de
liste en 2021 qu'en 2014 l'aef dont
étaient 29%
donc ce qui existe vraiment un très bon
chiffre alors qu'elles n'étaient que 18
% en 2014 mais malheureusement de 29 29%
band ans et 29% ils n'ont été que 23%
être élu maire donc c'est un écart quand
même qui pose problème qui montrent que
l'accès n'est pas égal pour les hommes
et pour les femmes
parmi les freins des difficultés à
convaincre les femmes de se présenter un
sentiment d'être illégitime et surtout
l'inquiétude à concilier les temps de
nombreux élus souhaitent garder leur
profession le point de vue de sonia bros
élu en février 2019
après la démission de bernard de bain la
maire de saint cyr l'école est réélu au
premier tour au mars 2020 avec plus de
55% des suffrages pour elle il s'agit du
monde a le plus proche de la réalité du
terrain
comme j'étais une femme je suis d'abord
passer par cc s1 un circuit assez connu
et puis finalement monsieur ben mon
maire a vite compris que voilà que
j'avais d'autres d'autres capacités et
le deuxième mandat en 2014
j'étais sa première adjointe et j'étais
en charge toujours de la communication
des événements mais aussi de
l'assainissement et des relations rh
l'association a elle aussi aimé quelques
idées limiter les mandats de maire à 2
réélection et plus de parité au sein
même des intercommunalités
ce qu'on préconise c'est que dans les
toutes les collectivités locales et à la
tête et un type les paritaire par
exemple un homme mère une femme
maire-adjointe ou une femme mère et un
homme premier adjoint parce que ce qu'on
a remarqué dans nos enquêtes en
particulier en bretagne c'est que pour
être première adjointe ou être 1re vice
président c'est vraiment ça aide à
devenir présidente ou ou mer dans les
yvelines 40 2 % des communes du
département ont des femmes premier
adjoint dans les hauts-de-seine et son
63 % au niveau national ces 33%